medical Daly is reporting that in
schools in nineteen states have started
to conduct annual weigh-ins for their
students to test their body mass index
which is used to determine if someone's
obese or overweight obviously and then
they're sending students home with the
results so they're monitoring how fat
the kid is and then they get the parents
involved States across from New York to
Arkansas Illinois are participating in
this and just FYI the body mass index is
calculated using weight and height and
then comparing both of those two growth
charts which add age and gender to the
equation let's look at some statistics
about childhood obesity okay so this is
from the Center for Disease Control
fittingly enough a childhood obesity has
more than doubled in children and
tripled as adolescents in the past
thirty years one in three children and
adolescents are considered overweight or
obese and the percentage of children 6
to 11 years old in the United States who
were obese increased from 7% in 1980 to
nearly 18% in 2010 and I'm sure that's
ticked up a couple points since then but
there's something about this that I just
don't like this constant surveillance
state and that the government should be
and schools should be telling you how to
eat and as much as I want people to eat
better and all that good stuff there's
just something that I don't like about
the feeling about this on both sides of
this because I think we there needs to
be some kind of awareness about the
childhood obesity problem obviously it's
a problem but number one and just going
back to our last thing maybe it's the
fatties fragments of meats that's been
laced with ammonia that's also adding to
the problem along with the inactivity
we're again it sounded horrible because
it's the fatty fragments that we're
gonna scrape off of the edge of the
cow's under chin so to put into this
giving them the worst fattiest crap in
the first place because of budget cuts
so they want to keep everything low cost
then all the kids get fat and then they
go we have fat kids well yeah so I
believe yeah and I do also think kids
move a lot less than I used to there's
me an old man talking because
I was an active child but so when you do
this though there's a way of doing and
also everyone's been not everyone but
I've heard stories people going to
doctors and then they go I'm in
perfectly good health but then the
doctor checks your love handle goes
you're totally obese they use the term
obese so flippantly and I think in wrong
terms at times it over blows it in some
cases you remember a couple years ago
that doctor said that Shaquille O'Neal
while he was still playing in the NBA
was technically obese they said
according to his body mass index which
is crazy because although he was never
the most fit guy in the world the guy
was you know one of the prime athletes
of the generation yeah I'm pretty sure
all the guys that he was dunking over
didn't think he was obese you know yeah
I am all for this no I don't
honest to god I just feel like you know
what we're gonna pay for it in the end
anyway I mean if you can it's just
frustrating to me that the that this has
become an epidemic and yes you know
there's social issues there's economic
issues and I agree with that these are
all valid points however it just feels
like we're where is the where's the what
is the word I'm like the responsibility
where is that I'm gonna step up and you
can I'm sorry but you can make some good
food choices you can you know teacher it
starts with the parents too it's like
and I'm not saying like Oh fat parents
create fat kit whatever but this is a
huge epidemic that's leading to diabetes
that's leading you know which now
insurance rates go up it is a huge you
it's a huge problem right and I'm sorry
so if you go home with a piece of paper
that's like hey your kids obese or your
this is this is this is you know
well yeah do something about it try I
think there's a risk of just shaming
these kids more we talk about bullying
all the time I know there's a front door
of your elementary school you're already
chained then you should go home with a
letter
they have very wide doors it's fat
you're fat like do something libertarian
right again maybe because I'd never had
to deal with it I agree
it came easier to me because there's
some people that are predisposed you
hear all those times but this is the
thing there's if we're worried about the
delivery system it is not 1978 it's not
1975 no one uses paper anymore send me
emails to parents if you worried about
the kids coming home with these papers
that they've read on the way back and
like they called me obese mom they send
it to the parents the kids don't have to
have be the delivery systems so our US
Postal Service is going down there's no
I don't want kids to feel you know the
backlash for this is like Oh kids are
sensitive they're gonna feel bad about
their there already oh they're already
enormous already real horrible like stop
the process before that happens and I'm
sorry like some of them are just their
wake-up calls you know what I mean yeah
so you think the risk of offending them
further that doesn't go as far as the
risk of them dot you know getting
diabetes they're already there are gonna
be marginalized and and everyone since
the dawn of time and it's so unfortunate
like pics on the FAC head but now no one
could get picked on because everyone's
so no there's an entire lunchroom of fat
like it's just if it's if you can get
them while they're young and try to
change some of their eating habits like
Michelle Obama and get them moving it so
it's gonna make for everything is gonna
get better everything is gonna get
better so final point on this isn't
something like this more important now
getting kids to be moving and to eat
right isn't it more important than ever
because now that we're gonna have
Obamacare in 2014 that we're all sort of
paying into the same system so we need
hell even if you only care about
economics so if you're at you know
Republican that wants limited government
and don't want them telling you what you
eat if you really only care about money
well you're gonna be paying in for all
these unhealthy people so it works out
economically to if you go back and I'm
your that has tons of money you're
thinking short term money you're like
nothing off more money right now yeah 25
years down the road I'll be dead I'll be
fine yeah millions are I'm gonna feel
them right now but later with some about
an epidemic of health issues there now
just nothing's well I think whether
China rid o Bhama cares is there later
they gonna have to pay for it more
anyway yeah I have this like thing that
I get really angry about that always
make people make fun of me but I hope
say like we can send people to the moon
and now we've got like the whole NASA
space program but we can't get like good
meat on a you know for our children it's
ridiculous to me I always goes back to
how we should defund NASA although from
what I understand that that low-calorie
ice cream on that the astronauts get is
that low-calorie ice cream that the
astronaut is low calorie okay